[Musique]
vanté le bilan du président de la
république sur ce marché parisien n'est
pas toujours bien accueillis ne m'en
parlez pas
mais c'est un nul
c'est la baguette de pain qui devrait
bientôt coûter plus cher une hausse de 5
à 10 centimes est prévue dans les jours
à venir en pause notamment et bien
l'augmentation du prix du blé nous avons
été attaqués
par l'arrière
nous avons été étranglée en même temps
par derrière nous n'avons pas vu les
visages des agresseurs à ce moment là
j'ai reçu un appel de la préfecture qui
me prévenait que j'avais ma permanence
qui habitait 25 10 et avec des thèmes
tels que collabos nazis en lien avec mon
vote concernant le pass sanitaires
c'était très mécanique et froid
ça ne s'est pas terminée quand tous les
effets ont été donnés il y a eu encore
des coups et puis un moment donné ils
ont décidé d'interrompre l'etna qui est
entré en éruption ce week-end pour la
troisième fois de l'année avec ce nuage
de cendres très impressionnant qu'à
crash de la montagne a pas de victime il
n'y a pas de dégâts plus bas taux est
stationné à proximité de vancouver à son
bord 50 de tonnes de produits chimiques
une partie de l'équipage a pu être
évacué les conséquences écologiques
s'annonce déjà désastreux sont les
experts car l'incendié dégagent des
fumées toxiques toxiques alors enlevé le
6 le couloir n'a pas d'importance
mais je l'enlève les
annonces
ce à quoi sert exil ours et organisé
vous voyez cette division 7 cette
controverse au sein des milieux
populaires pour ne pas qu ensemble
quelle que soit gens me dire vous
abonner quelles que soient ses
convictions spirituelles et d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens n'ont pas dans ce pays
que nous puissions améliorer nos
services publics partager les richesses
sauver la planète entre emmanuel macron
et eric zemmour vous votez paris je sais
pas qui sera au deuxième tour non et
voulez que je vous dise oui est-ce que
je pense oui c'est qu'eric zemmour est
un très bon candidat de premier tour
mais pas du tout second poème essai
non vous l'enlevez pack voilà
voilà très bien bah vous voyez là là
vous respecter la laïcité non c'est pas
vrai non madame non mais bien mais vous
me servez au crb de moi comme punching
ball mais pas du tout je suis désolé
vous vous taisez vous ou très bien mais
j'ai encore le droit
pour déchoir de la nationalité et
expulser les délinquants étrangers nés
dans leur pays d'origine est pas une
poubelle mais c'est pas la france
réussit une poubelle la france non plus
rassurantes est-ce qu'il est encore un
allié potentiel
chacun fait valoir ses différences c'est
le jeu électoral et nous n'avons pas
peur de la concurrence vous savez quand
vous avez un resto et que vous avez une
clientèle installée qu'en face de vous
un nouveau resto ouvre et bien ça vous
challenge ça vous oblige à adapter la
carte le service à être encore meilleur
condamné par la justice pour ses propos
racistes et on lui laisse cet espace là
je crois qu'il faut se ressaisir
je pense quand même le système
médiatique dans lequel c'est quoi le
système le système médiatique c'est
quand même toute cette place qu'il a
dans toutes les émissions
dont j'assume
vous répétez je répète vous répète
aujourd'hui
so lu ment je répète aujourd'hui je
répète s'avère une trappe à terre c'est
pas une condamnation qui fera taire puis
il est raciste et des condamnés pour ça
d'ailleurs peut vraiment fréquenter
quelqu'un qui est raciste et moi c'est
ce que je crois rêver bien des problèmes
à ce que j'ai envie que mes enfants des
voitures et lui et pas les impôts c'est
que ce système est une question adressée
par des maghrébins absolument c'est
pratiquement majoritairement ses baskets
qui ont été vendus hier aux enchères
chez chauffe chez
sotheby's pardon elle avait donc été
portée par michael jordan son cinquième
match au cours de sa première saison
chez les chicago bulls on appelle ça un
castel château en catalan c'est une
manifestation typique dans le pays
voyez hein c'est impressionnant il ya
même des enfants tout en haut de la
pyramide qui participent